okay for those who are joining us on the
live stream this is one of an infinite
series of meetings about incremental
updates to or from language we've got a
bunch of topics today
okay first is about generalizing
extending joining across join across is
not a function that I have to say um I
end up using that much um missing to
bring join across the same level as join
in SQL we're only doing equi-join
okay who is going to discuss this Carlo
okay so yeah so the only thing that you
can do with the key or key and rule is
saying these two these two values have
to be equal so in general you in SQL
you're allowed for a predicate there so
you instead of doing equal you could do
greater than right so what we're saying
is those two in this case we're joining
these by taking every time we see the
same key in these two different
associations we are
joining them how so this is
what is this doing here
so so basically it's taking from the
first Association so it's joining each
time the Association first list and
second list each time ta matches
and otherwise what's it doing throwing
it away okay so it keeps only those
associations for which the the there is
a match of that I see I get it yeah the
the most general one if you wanna start
from the end the most general type of
join is the cross join which we're
missing which would be can be written
with outer in in their own poll from
language so that's the very end of the
other notebook right now okay but but in
general wait a minute
okay when the keys of values when these
are all the same okay which the values
associated with key a
in the AI of the Domus those associated
with ki be in the BJ so that's a case
where the keys you are comparing are
different exactly
would you you know you could do things
like for example you can add on the key
a you could have a string a on on the
key B you could have a string pattern
and so the comparison function rather
than being equal is stream can execute
yeah I understand
determine when to allow association so
it already has a fourth argument yes
but but the fourth argument we still
need okay
but so because it still applies even if
this is the outer case where it allows
unmatched a ai and BJ what
no no cross is bigger than outer cross
the cross is really the cross product
outer means to just allow for missing
so it's actually if you click there's a
link to Wikipedia in the notebook join
in SQL there are examples there okay
let's not look at that right now I'm
trying to understand what is this here
so that one is so imagine that he the
key on the Left
takes values 1 & 2 and the key on the
right takes values 2 & 3 so they never
match but if you do outer you're gonna
have one unmatched to a matched a
matched 3 a matched 4
so it's not the front cross product
I see that the result will be to some
length with the Sun not the product as
opposed to the product
probably the wrong name for it but
that's the well it's not exactly the
song because if you have things repeated
on both sides then they will be
multiplied and sort of exploded in a
cross product way but only within the
groups like if you have two things with
the same value on the left and three on
the right then the end will be the
combination of six even for the inner
join um okay so hold on second so key
collision functions
minute okay so you're proposing that
there be a third argument that is an
alternative to these string named join
specs that says what that is the
predicate it's boolean function with two
arguments right which is a predicate for
given two keys should they be joined no
leaving two associations should be
joined
what really we open it given to
associations which are I see in the AI
and bi but then once we are actually
joining those associations wait a minute
I see so the key collision function
applies once those associations are
being joined right because we're just
using the join function yes
and the joint function for associations
should have a key collision function
does the joint function for associations
do
icky collision function because the body
a very large function
Yeah right so given
or is there some notion of Association
join that we need to have
you
that maybe as a generalization of both
these things
you
see this is okay so this is lists of
associations okay so what what are you
actually proposing here so what you're
proposing is that the fourth argument no
the third argument here also what's that
yes third argument which is here allowed
to be keys okay there's a fourth
argument here
well that stays we you need it even if
you have a function as the third
argument need the points back because
you can use the function as a third
argument then say left right inner outer
cross
so how do we determine so if this is a
function again that function is the
predicate for whether two particular
associations there should be joined and
what you're saying here is that we are
degenerating that predicate to just
being does this key agree between those
associations right in this case yes so
it shows how you can reproduce the cases
that already exist in the spec using
this function does this want to be
something different like join across by
it's not a by I actually the one we
already have is a by function this one
is not a by there's like sort it has a
yeah I understand it has a binary
operator
which is the the by case yeah okay or
the equality case reading
well but you might want okay so your
point is given to associations so the
thing is really this is a predicate
you
which joins elements of a Sox 1 and a
Sox - when
pred gives true
you
when the results of applying pred gives
true that correct yes mm-hmm blind -
what - up to - both no it's not a stock
one it's to the elements which joins
element spread to the elements okay a
seventh care of elements he I do right
yes pair of elements which is AI BJ so
the generalization of this whole thing
is a function
um it's kind of an outer when
I claim okay so let's let's just fill
out what I mean by that so it's the
combiner function
the list one list - and then am i right
am I wrong here then it's a predicate
there and this takes every elements of
list 1 it takes pairs of elements from
list one and list two and when pred
gives true it it gives them in the final
list and it's actually a flattened outer
yeah and all like it's like a tuples
what's that go ahead that's also just in
their specification the thing I just
said yeah it correspond to Jace back in
ER right you know I actually think this
case is easier to understand in some
ways than these cases here with
individual keys in other words you're
just taking out all possible pairs here
what function do we have is it groupings
is it tuples which would take out all
possible pairs
I mean outer would clearly you know an
outer f of you know a b c d e well it'll
certainly look at all possible pairs
there this is an outer with a flattened
at the end which isn't it strange that i
know it's not really an outer it's
really but what is it is it a is it
outer with flooding is more like
distribute okay but but the main point
is that this is doing something where
there's a predicate deciding what goes
into that list yes and i'm concerned
about the cases in which for a given key
in list one there will be several in
list two that give true what's going to
happen then you get
okey what this is doing is the whole
okay so hold on hold on hold on
the case of associations first point is
this operation of a flattened outer in
other words taking taking you know pairs
an element from the first lesson element
from the second list what is the what's
our best way of doing that is it
distribute or is it flattened about er
well if you try to pose with a list of
the lists it will be similar it's just
that we returned pairs rather than F of
them yes right okay because two poles
doesn't have those tuples have an
alternate head specification or not I
think it doesn't okay but the point here
is that what we are saying is keep only
so even an even simpler case of this
would be you know something like this it
would be like pairings of both we've got
some background noise would be nice to
avoid pairings of lists one is to
predicate
okay which gives all possible pairings
from list one and list two for which
predicate gives true
so this is a two-dimensional version of
select so select list come up read right
this is multi select of some kind except
in selecting you need to first sort of
you know form everything and then select
and in this case it will avoid those
things that are not matching the
condition at construction time well
there's no construction so like doesn't
have construction because what this is
doing the pairings here I'm just saying
in this case if those things were
elements II won you know
let's call them a1 a2 a3 okay
b1 b2 okay then what I'm saying is in
this way of doing it this doesn't have a
function that's being applied so this
would just be a 1 B 2 you know a 3 B 1
whatever it is might be the only ones
that satisfy the give true with the
predicate am I making sense yeah
you
so I mean that's the more general I mean
it's that thing with a function being
applied to each of those
right so so I don't know what the what
is the version of join that can have a
key collision function
it's just association isn't it how do
you do this if you want to take to
associations and you know a goes to 1 b
goes to 2
and how do I do this do I say just
association of that comma
I think it's merge what's your little
one oh yeah maybe it is right see goes
to three
you
you
I think you want a key or the value for
a to have something different in the
second one
what's going on here in the function to
work the third argument since second
event well should the message okay
shouldn't I would think it should
generate a message in that well it's
probably thinking it's the operator form
oh yes that's right that's what it does
think it is okay but so
not the same operation no because in
this case you are bound to group by keys
and for a predicate it doesn't it's not
restricted to keys right okay but but so
just tell me again given these two
associations right if I were to just say
join of those two associations I get
that result right I'm asking how do I
put the key collision function into the
join just understand what I'm asking
right so that that's one issue we got to
figure out how we make the analog of a
join with a non-trivial key collision
function you know but this is it's a
different problem it's a related problem
because we're gonna need a key collision
function in the joint across stuff oh
you really do know no I know we have a
key collision function join a cross I'm
trying to refactor join a cross so that
it can be working so that exam get what
I'm saying yeah this should arguably
have a thing that goes to the
association guide page by the way if
it isn't the generalization of join
across then apply across
you
yes probably
yes it probably is um
okay so what is oh look Catanese
elements from it that's the function we
need
why doesn't catenate have a key
collision function or does it yeah why
doesn't catenate
well in the first place it pork so some
lists I don't care I mean the question
is it should have a key collision
function that allows it to do the right
thing for associations when it has
associations but for that it would have
to only work on associations not noise
why it just ignores it if it's given
lists right well then it looks to be a
more sort of in a more narrow case not
generally what do you say we're saying
key collision function specifies what to
do with keys that collide in if it is
given associations okay but you can have
more than two associations so how do you
do that
so you'll need a like an array key
collision functions to choose which
Association to use or how I'm not sure
but but the key collision function how
does the key collision function usually
work with let's journey across no no oh
it's only four join across well I mean
look clearly
right this case of giving a function can
work perfectly well you take n keys and
you return and keys
right
in fact the general case there is very
straightforward the general case is
you're given a list of the keys of the
colliding keys and you return a new list
of keys to use you don't get a list of
clarin keys get one flight
we can't no no this is pairs of elements
I can get yeah you get one and you get
out - yeah yeah right okay yes I
understand because the list would be
treating anyway right right right okay
fair enough okay but so let's go back
over here to ask so you say that the
analog is apply across but I'm saying
that there's a function here that's that
is the predicate version of outer so to
speak to get what I'm saying
I think it's almost selective tuples
okay let's see what whether we believe
that okay so select tuples so that then
let's say we can have a whole list of
it's a list of lists yeah a list of
lists here so that's a 1 a 2 a 3 B 1 B 2
etcetera etcetera and now where's the
two poles so to put the two poles
already takes that argument and it will
return the list of all tuples and now
select we'll take the the predicate no
list of lists okay oh that's right
that's very nice
yeah okay I now select it's around that
without Medicaid that takes each of the
tuples and says yes or no right exactly
so in principle we could imagine a
combined function which is more
efficient because it doesn't that you
have to generate all the tuples right
yeah that's an interesting function at
its own right so in this case of the
joint across then this is so tuples
doesn't have a no it has a number of
results right but it never gets the
opportunity to give it a head right to
mix it okay so now what you're saying is
so this is the fundamental operation and
what you're saying is that there is a
join version of that or in general and F
version of that but honestly it's not
even worth doing the F version of this
for the general case you might as well
just apply the F apply level one the F
to this thing exactly
okay so but in the case of specific case
of associations you're saying I mean one
point is that we this would be a general
join across that works with more than
two associations right so let's imagine
I mean let's imagine there was an apply
across it's really it's really let's
just imagine it was something like
thread I think that's quite the right
name but but we'd something like this
where we would have the first set of
elements second set of elements then as
a predicate which determines whether to
keep a pair and then there's that third
argument I don't understand very well so
then join a cross becomes thread across
of join I'm not mistaken and then that
predicate in the simple case would be
accept still if you do throw the cross
of join you miss the opportunity to have
collisions I'm aware because I am aware
of that
okay so let's imagine that it was this
catenate with a key collision function
which I think Anna is gonna lead okay
most beautiful way to do it but but that
that would be the idea that I'm making
sense yep okay so
and what's the fourth argument
now doing so that predicate that they
this is a pretty grotesque version of
that predicate right the thing that is
going to do the and of weather
Oh for a bunch of keys okay so this is
the simple case of a single key that
agrees right
so in general so the simple case of this
I mean I think it is a shame that China
cross only has pass
not a shame
okay what I'm saying but it only can
deal with pairs here in my opinion it is
it will be it will be harder to specify
a left and right and the altar joints in
the spirit as it's done in German cross
if you have multiple thanks because
you'll need to specify it complex you
know things and how how that is going to
work why I mean the left left and right
it's just first and lost really it's the
analog of that it's the analog of left
and right why because you are either
taking the first one you're taking the
last one that's not no that's for the
collision function but Larry was
speaking about the the fourth argument
explain the four but I thought the
fourth argument is so default inner
means that it has to match
so that and what has left mean left
means that even if there is nothing that
matches on the right you keep the
version on the left I say when you add
missing and matched for the ones that
don't match right is the opposite outer
is left and right
okay so my point has been that if you
extend the you know the function to more
than two sets of things to lists of
things then you'll be much harder to do
only inner outer and an cross it's yeah
to do like you should call them like
first second third fourth and then you
also have the combinations like first
and second you know one thing that's
really a pity here is that we it doesn't
give one much you know every time I look
at this I have to remember what is this
really doing yeah I think that the
examples are a bit too abstract here if
you look at the examples that are for
example in Wikipedia page of join with
employees and departments it's a lot
clearer well okay you can propose some
other examples for this but but I mean
you
the thing here I mean I'm not thrilled
with the name join across
tell me again how to think about so I
mean these are it's a contingent set of
joins
between adjoins in our sense of join
join as in just you know you're joining
one association with the other
association right right that's what it's
doing correct yes okay but it's doing it
a little bit more like complicated way
exactly because of all the other aspects
you can use well no no it's it's it's
doing I mean an alternative name could
have been something like join tuples
and if we did something like that oh I
mean
drawing tuples isn't bad except for the
fact that the only thing that actually
does what tuples does we don't support
it which is cross doing
okay obvious
can support that but the issue here is
you
that would deal with the case okay so
this case
okay and then the simplest cases there's
a predicate there right
and the issue is how can we have
representations of that predicate that
are fairly simple
so
join tuples let's imagine we did that
okay there's a predicate there now what
else do we need
if we did this joint tuples thing
you
that is basically saying I mean we could
even do that these things could talk to
I'll be lists if we wanted to but but
let's assume it's associations
um
may not be the best name but let's let's
just try to understand the function okay
okay so
we're trying to understand what that
predicate thing is
and we've got these cases here
join those ones in which the key is the
same
you guys are silent here so
you've got in general you want to have
so that one would be hash one sub it's
actually more complicated than this
right because it's for all of the hash
sub I in that list there that particular
key is the same right so this is a
simple case with to write one
alternative idea I'm thinking I'm
looking at tuples to pulse width
Association and it does nothing right
now is there any possibility that we
could reuse that freedom there it's
possible to post with her with a list of
associations what should we do well know
it's that this is a different case
because this is lists of lists of
associations see what I'm saying
lists of lists oh I see okay look let's
this is going to take another hour to go
through this particular thing I agree
that it's an important thing I have
never liked this function we kind of
added it as a kind of you know let's
have something that is like SQL
functionality for this okay I think we
need to make it our own in a more
effective way and that requires you know
some generalization and some
understanding of how I mean my guess is
that there's going to be a joint tuples
and a joint tuples by effectively by
making sense
and that this buy is effectively you
know just saying ki there would be the
thing that would use yeah I mean by
would be well hash of ki would certainly
do it that make sense color you
understanding I'm not not happy about
that because hash of key and if you
allow that
that's a unary function and then the
Equality is kind of implied no no that's
what by means oh okay
do you understand the two cases there's
the predicate case which takes an NRI
function Missouri yeah okay this is
elegant sort and sort by right yeah well
in that case just explicit capital K key
new works
for which to a function to our
association oh I see because it applies
like that you're saying yeah
but also still one if we even if we
design these general functions the
problem was joined across all those to
remain because we got afloat join it but
in the trash we can't because for
instance for what we are doing right now
for SQL we can't support it the general
spec for these functions you are
planning to design yes you can they're
just multiple joiner crosses well there
will be problems in like a big impedance
mismatch I think between what we can
support what we need and what this
general functionality will provide okay
you know what the only difference is
we're having n n elements in the list
rather than just two and clearly you can
do that by just going through in pairs
but that's not the main point here
that's not the main point the main point
is you've asked for a generalization of
join across that is essentially this
right well we must forest several know
you want the case where they're only two
elements on this list yes fine I don't
care
you know if if that's all that SQL can't
support which I don't believe you know
so be it but that's not the function
we're going to have all right so just
because SQL is too lame to deal with
that which it isn't because you can
obviously do it in pairs but but let's
let's keep going here because we're
trying to make something which people
can actually understand all I'm saying
is that these are somewhat different
problems they are related but they
aren't the same I I think that the
biggest problem really is that during
tuple probably will not have that fourth
argument ace back yeah that's what if I
and I mean there's still value in having
that
also join across gives you the guarantee
that the thing you get out is let's say
array like all the associations will
have the same keys the tuples version
I'm not sure well I think it by the way
someone is asking on the livestream
about datasets and what this does on
datasets does anybody even know
you know going across some data sets yes
like join a cross between if there are
two arguments if the arguments are two
data sets
because data sets can be lists of
associations obviously another one sure
it works in two data sets right but
should it they presumably should it
might but the mother on the other hand
if data sets are nested deeply nested no
then it's hopeless
so that's probably the reason why it
wasn't generally implemented okay
actually what this person is asking if
data sets if it works if join if
something like SQL join works on data
sets we should make that clearer in the
documentation well the problem there is
that we don't have a specific table or a
type of data set that will be strictly
two-dimensional yeah I understand okay
let's just come back to this for a
minute okay so we've got these two
functions conceptually join tuples and
join tuples by I think I understand
those functions and what they do right
so this one has an implicit equality
just like sort by has an implicit
comparator I'm a making sense
mm-hmm right and so now the question is
the the part that we haven't got um is
this
[Music]
for example to get this case
so with all the keys are the same so
that might be some kind of you know
special syntax here for
I'm not sure exactly how that would work
but but to deal with that case but now
this case for the more general
the more general J spec how do I think
about that yeah
just what I'm saying only okay so this
one here is allow only those for which
they match
okay so in this case what we're doing is
we're adding with a missing unmatched
when it is good that you could specify a
sort of a list of such specs assume that
they are applied sort of pairwise like
four one and two then two and three and
so on okay
although don't we already have just like
we have key collision function right
which is don't we already have something
which has this notion that is that
what you're given hear what you're fed
to the predicate what the predicate gets
okay so this is the question is is what
does the predicate get so it is
you see what I'm saying what does it
what is it given when there is no
corresponding matching allow AI for
which there is no matching BJ so that
means that the predicate that even when
the predicate fails there no but wait
yeah yeah so that means that even when
the predicate is false you want to keep
the thing on the left or the thing on
the right what does it mean to keep so
it means to keep is that your Eric join
look look at the look at the example
there is an example with left yeah that
one
so basically
you
there's one there that doesn't match
okay
C goes to acts
okay so effectively this is useful when
you're doing something like no no I
don't stand this case I don't understand
what's doing here okay what is it let me
give you a less dry example imagine
you're you're taking all the employees
and joining them with all the employees
that work from you don't have a manager
in ER would drop you out
but sorry isn't this just the case that
a it goes to two and a goes to three do
not match so it chooses a goes to 2
because that's the last one why does it
say C goes to unmatched I don't stand
with the way it works is imagine you
have a list of Association where you
have employee ID manager ID and then you
want to match you have the the arrow
right so you have the rule so employee
goes to manager now if you have an
employee that doesn't have the man a
manager because it's the CEO in ER would
drop it from the list instead if you do
it this way you get you get nothing for
the manager you get missing a matched
and for all the keys associated with the
with the manager say I don't know the
tenure yeah ok ok but I'm not I'm still
not completely getting it so it walk me
through in more theoretical terms here
in join tuples ok where there is a
predicate what is the third argument
really doing what is the general case of
the third argument
did you understand my question
yes okay so there's a okay so if you had
three there is a version of this which
is first second third let's say that
says keep old so if you say first for
example keep a 1 a 2 a 3 even if there
is no match in B 1 B tours you wanna see
two
so the general model will be a function
that will be giving you a list of
boolean saying which ones have to be
true to keep the entire thing yeah
predicate is telling you I don't
understand why this third argument is
not part okay so what you're doing is
you're you're filling in missing stuff
even when the predicate doesn't say to
do the join no yes yeah I mean when it
says don't do the join you're saying I'm
ignoring that I'm going to do the join
because I'm manufacturing something that
is joinable right yes yes except except
that you are doing that in a separate
stage so that it's not a multiplication
it's like you first do a join which
basically kind of multiplies things and
then you add things from the left or
from the right like a sum so it's like
multiplying you're thinking
implementational ii let's not think that
way because we're thinking about the
predicate determines which tuples okay
pred determines which tuples are kept
okay so what what you have to imagine is
that for each of the tuples there is
there is a last element which is like
kind of a drama
kind of what of a Joker Joker
yes okay it's that it's wild guessing
what the translation from Italian of
Joker never mind yeah baby yeah um okay
so it's it's kind of a wild card so it
always matches and it's determined by
the last argument whether it's kept in
the end or not
I think this isn't quite general enough
I think I think there's a better way to
think about this because what what's
happening is okay which tuples are kept
so for example the the
the join here might be a to be to see
one that might be one of the things
you're joining together by making sense
so we might be saying catenate a to be
one cc2 let's say okay might be one of
the ones that is kept according to the
predicate yes but if you specify if you
say that the a ones are special then you
want something that works like pad bed
right
and so you keep a one if you even if you
didn't match with anything and then you
pad it so they alright I understand I
understand I understand so what this is
is
it doesn't say even if this predicate
predicate determines which tuples are
kept right even if the predicate if
predicate if the predicate fails
on a two-pole
why is the tuple being be rewritten then
you're going to end up with catenate of
essentially a two filler filler
is that right yeah and and the spec
basically the spec when you see left
your left hold on the only thing you
know is the predicate fails on the
triple in this case right so you're
saying even when the predicate fails on
the triple I'm going to manufacture a
fake triple
that has filler
which elements
Filip for all the keys in a - is that
correct no it has filler for all the
keys so it has fillers so that the
resulting things is an array
so they'll fill filler for all the keys
in B and C which are not not but no no
it'd be specific B 1 and C 2 because the
B sub i's might have different keys in
them know the different B sub i's might
have different keys in them no they
can't
why not I don't know at least for join
across they can't well okay but I'm
trying to understand the general case
here yeah III don't know if you can meet
the general keys well I'm trying to
understand the general case right in the
general case they do not have to have
the same keys I think that's correct
because the example just often they're
not lookin to write doesn't have the
same keys the B's and C's I think no
they do right or not they do not they
have B's and C's that the example the
next one the one with the left I think
that's a confusing example because it
has two lists with two associations like
least they all have the same keys each
list is an array yeah okay fair enough
but otherwise known as each list is a
data set could be thought of as a data
set that is a squared you know a
rectangular data set I think can you
change the capital access to lowercase X
and our case Y because I think that's a
confusing example but we can fix it
so there the lowercase X and our case Y
this one here the other capital X just
just below so that it's different from
the other ones work is why well okay yes
exactly I evaluate that and now change
it'll copy the examples and change left
to right
I think this clear clears things up goes
to Y okay so that's just purely joining
those things so it always thinks it
always takes the best blueprint one of
these lists in this case it's the second
one and then it fills the missing keys
was missing
I think the coefficient thing is that
because we have two and two two
associations and two lists left and
right it's confusing
yeah I know so we should fix that
example so if I put here a goes to four
C goes to Q or something okay now
meanwhile if I do that with right it
will generate three things I claimed my
right yes okay right guarantees that you
always have at least as many as there
are in the second one left at least the
second element right so okay so fine so
that's using okay so it's a question of
which one do you use the template that
correct yes the template is always ABC
in this case it's more like which ones
should never be deleted it is the
template if you inner outer left or
right there is always ABC well the
difference is that what you're saying is
basically never delete something on the
left even if it's a matched
statement something else as a template
for left and right you can think of one
of these two collections as being a
template
yes and then for outer for outer we'll
have to think a bit differently about
this for outer the template is a kind of
a join of left and right in a way
right by the way this missing a matched
and since this is quite like padding
maybe we should gain an option to say
instead of missing a match that once
nearer there
that's a reasonable idea zero well
whatever it is something to bring
whatever like a default oh right okay so
I'm sorry let's go back here to this
again for a second um
okay okay look let me make a mess of
comments here you know
was a unnecessary
rapidly designed function
sadly not even considered experimental
here you know it's too close to you know
it was done to pander to basically SQL
ISM and I don't think we fully
understood
you know what the clean specification of
it is the good news is we're now doing
that so let's go ahead um so this you
know for me this joined tuples joined
tuples by thing is pretty easy to
understand what it's doing it's pretty
easy description it takes all tuples
from here
and yes we can do only the the binary
case that the beginning all pairs
of a ibj
such that that predicate is true
okay
that's rather easy to understand
actually I think you can't generalize
these enough so that we cover all cases
also used by join across blast argument
all you have to do is to specify sort of
a list which ones for which ones of
these we want to keep them even even if
they are unmatched so for the three of
them you can say you keep one and two
but not three and that would mean that
all right let's try writing that down
okay so
this is the list of let's say always
keep always kept always kept a terrible
option name but this is always kept and
and then it's like default element arrow
you know missing unmatched or whatever
it is yeah and effectively mean left
join in the first pair and right join in
the second pair and in the in the last
pair yes but but okay but so wait a
minute the predicate so even if the
predicate fails this is saying I don't
quite understand even when the predicate
fails on a given pair for example or a
given triple
this is saying when the predicate fails
make up something on which the predicate
would succeed I'm thinking that this
this this biggest deviation is not
enough because like you could do if you
see always kept one two three is that
outer outer or is it let's try to
understand what it means when the
predicate fails invent an element on
which the predicate would succeed is
that correct no it's more like you do
all the things with the predicate and
then you check that you match two older
one and all the threes and if you didn't
then you basically append them no no but
but let's be very specific here let's be
very specific in the end the thing is
going to say join a2 b2 c1 for example
okay or catenate those things yeah what
I'm telling you is that if join of a
let's say if you're doing a one with b2
and c2 yes and you have always kept one
but you've already it depends on whether
you've already matched a1 with something
else no no no no that's not right
because because we're looking at
specific okay these things have many
keys in them right we're not looking at
the point when we're doing the
catenation we're no longer looking
inside the predicate to see what keys it
talked about
no no no that's not what I meant but I
just want to see what the code looks
like but seeing what I'm telling is that
imagine that you're doing a 1 B 1 C 1
and that matches and then you do a 1 B 2
C 1 and that doesn't match
even if we're seen by man it's not
matching it fails the profile the
predicate right the predicate kills so
if the second fails the predicate but
the first hasn't failed then you don't
do anything
I don't understand this so let's imagine
it's a 2 B 1 C 2 fails the predicate yes
and then you have to ask yourself let's
say you want to keep all the A's if a to
succeeded elsewhere then you don't need
to add it
what are you talking about how it works
but that's crazy okay so wait a second
so you're saying oh my god what a messy
complicated thing no no let's try to be
more precise let's try to make it more
sensible okay what you're saying is that
that's totally weird it's not what is
the piece of code what's the piece of
code that tells you
you're saying if I ever kept a to
yes and you don't need to hold it with
missing a match because it has matched
it
yes you only
you only use that rule for missing a
matched for those of your A's that
didn't match anything using the
predicate so you first sort of to the
predicate part okay okay so what you're
done saying is that's really weird okay
then look at where do we wait second
then look at the AI which never made it
through any predicate right is that
correct yes weird it's like a padding
you know but no it's not like padding
it's kind of what like bearings it's the
other direction but it's if you think
about it it's really useful because when
so if you think about the example of
people like managers and employees the
UPS in most cases you absolutely don't
want to drop the CEO from the table of
employees even if that person doesn't
have a manager
and you don't even want to duplicate all
the people who do ever manager
well can't fix the database and say that
they see always his own manager okay
fine whatever but but but let me again I
want to understand in a more theoretical
level what this means look at the AI
which never made it
which never gave true with any predicate
wow that's a really weird criterion that
helped me make that less weird
so in other words we're looking at the
predicate goes and looks at every pair
to imagine or every end tuple
I just don't know still I think the one
part of the confusion is that for and to
understand the dis left and right we
have to think in terms of sets so kind
of a set of matched things and then the
set of unmatched well when you are
thinking about the predicate you are
kind of considering zooming in to one
single thing out of them so that's why
it makes a bit confuse the thing okay
so you're saying okay so here's let's
think about it a different way okay
let's imagine that there's the predicate
before we do any operations right
and in this case here okay we could ask
of these which ones survived
those may not survive when we apply the
predicate got what I'm saying yes
exactly and then you separately consider
those that won't survive later right so
we've broken this into a group that
survives in a group that doesn't survive
right okay and now all the ones that are
non survivors what do we do with okay so
okay so let's let's imagine okay
so then then the what we want to say
here is
you
consider the tuples which survived
cut
okay those are fine those are just in
the results then also consider the
tuples that fail the predicate
okay so we have one of those tuples
let's say it's that tuple fails the
predicate okay now how do we modify this
how do I mean what what are we being
told to do so that okay so imagine that
this is an example of a tuple that fails
the predicate
right so now tell me what to do to that
to poll so Carol templates for B and C
that will be kind of filled with
missings and so you do catenate but not
with some real B&C but with exactly what
we need is a essentially a failure
function here that is applied to
you
Oh
okay so then what we would do is apply
the failure function
to any tuple that doesn't pass the
predicate to modify it in some way that
we specify that correct well if you
generalize then yes but the question is
do we want to keep the constraint that
we start with arrays and we return an
array if we do then that that function
can't be arbitrary okay fine but what
feature does that function have to have
that it returns a list of the same
length right yeah is that correct that
it's a list of the same length or is it
something more detailed that involves
the keys being conforming that did that
depends on which constraints we want to
preserve if you want to preserve the
array constrained and it has to be more
specific than that okay but maybe it's a
function maybe it's more of a an auto
mapped function so to speak that we'll
just put in I mean right now do we have
something which will fluff out an
association to have certain keys in it
to get what I'm saying like add some
missing keys with the missing values we
do have it I think take does that
something so we want to Union that's
doing that okay fine often
okay to make the Association conforming
I mean so what you're saying is okay
there's the predicate that says great
just put me in the output right this is
the thing that says how to modify
something that fails the predicate and
what possibility for failure function is
it just drops it
okay another possibility it is it tries
to patch it up am I making sense YUM but
then do also it is sort of clear that
like left okay if I were just two of
them we'll just a and B's then it's kind
of clear what left means what right
means what do they mean tell me what
they mean so left means that you apply
failure function to all like the set of
failed ace nope it doesn't set of failed
bees in the left case it's the set of
failed bees that you apply it to no
because you're patching no patching the
bees ancient piece but the point of aids
no but you don't need to apply it to the
ACE because the A's are just fine
no a split into a set that matches
that's why is the predicate and the set
that doesn't okay
and so you apply failure function to all
A's that don't survive the break it but
you patch them was the certain you know
certain template that comes from bees
that's not what I thought left it I
thought what light did know left means
that you keep all A's
but for non surviving A's you patch them
with the you know this stuff that comes
from bees
but missing values like keys come from
bees but they have missing values okay
so what you're effectively saying is
that what you would do is there's a key
Union
Union of all the keys in the AIDS the
bees in the Seas yes but but I mean to
unify to more than two arguments I I
think that they look my point about more
than two arguments I don't care about
the implementation right now I think it
is useful for understanding what's going
on to look at the more than two argument
case sure sure but stay on the one thing
which I'm a bit concerned is that also I
think Carly express this doubt that it
might be that are the general spec that
we have for you know binary operations
like we have for joining cross might not
it might not be possible to express the
same if you have more than two okay I
don't think you're right about that I
think it will be clearer with more than
two will understand what we're actually
doing which you guys don't really
understand this painting operation
difference because I can paste some code
in the chat to see what's happening when
you do move to for once no I well we're
gonna have to say is that we might come
up with the examples which are combined
from pairwise joins which we will never
be able to reproduce with the joints
with three arguments or more or no
matter what spec we invent okay you
might be right
all I'm trying to do is to understand
this in its in a slight generalization
the right left thing which I think using
us okay so I don't care whether we
decide in the end that we're only going
to take the two case I personally think
the N case is gonna be less difficult to
understand on the two case but we'll
find out right so I just want to
understand last thing here when there is
a failure function right the failure
function deals with those two poles
which didn't pass the predicate right
yes so please tell me what you do with
those two poles so depends on which
which type of speculator left back so
you apply failure function to all non
surviving A's no no the failure function
is being applied to two poles so let's
take the case
the left spec with with a pair right so
here's the thing that supply the failure
function being applied what do I do
well in this case assuming that all B's
have the same keys or or maybe not what
do you do you take the keys from B could
you put yourself on mute it wasn't
coming from me so so what you do is that
you take the keys from B and you go
ahead you take all the things from P so
you take the key union of all the beats
of eyes is that correct well you take
that particular B in your case if you
are applying it to a and B like a 2 and
B 1 you take keys from B and you set all
values for B 1 to missing and then you
join a 2 and this new missing kind of
skeleton of b1 with missing values okay
so hold on you take b1 yeah and you
replace all values of b12 with missing
let's take a specific example here okay
so let's say we say a goes to the first
thing here is a 1 well it's called a K a
1 goes to 1 K a 2 goes to 2 etc right
yes for the B's is there is one
important thing here once we think about
A's and B's
we still think about tuples but I have
to point out that this failure operation
is not done on tuples it's done it's not
done on the multiplied you know things
it's done on just a set of mislike set
of non surviving A's
but there is no notion of okay the
federal non surviving a is your claim is
that it is basically being done to Pat
it out yes give it all the so in other
words because this is essentially kind
of a sum operation which is sort of
added to product the only the only way
you can do it is by imposing that all
these have the same keys because then it
doesn't matter with which B or from
which B you are sort of constructing
this missing template but dude does the
B have all that you assume that every
key and B is missing then yes yes yes
but my point has been that all set of
bees and all set of A's and all set of
C's will have to have the same keys like
among themselves so they have to be a
race otherwise this operation doesn't
make sense
well you're saying that among the atha
by all a sub i have the same set of keys
yes if I have the same set of keys same
different set of possibly different set
of keys but same within themselves well
Fame within the B sub i's yes yes right
okay and then in that case it doesn't
matter which particular B you take to
create that's why I keep on talking
about key Union and so on yes yes so
could there be missing okay so but but
you were saying the whole argument from
Colo was that some of those keys could
be missing and one of the ace of eyes
that was this whole point yes you need
to take in that's right so you take the
key Union of each of those elements
there right and then you're padding
okay so the key point so to speak not to
make a pun but the key point is that
first
okay the ASA by B sub I etcetera must
each
be essentially rectangular with respect
to keys right when they are not
padding function
must say how to pad them right okay
now given that
but there's two different things going
on here
one is that a key is missing and the
other is that a key doesn't agree
I don't think you mean with us doesn't
agree as per predicate yes that's
correct
yes exactly and one is product and
another is kind of a padding or some if
you wish in terms of sets so it's kind
of like if you split the sets of set of
a into two different subsets the ones
which match and the ones like pass the
predicate and the ones which don't and
those which pass the predicate they are
sort of multiplied in a way by some
different set like a by B but there was
which don't their self just padded and
added to the result I understand what
you're saying but it's a hack let's try
not sign it without hack I think there
are two different things going on one is
that if these are not rectangular they
get padded okay but then there's a
separate decision to make about whether
you include something that was padded in
so to speak whether you consider to it
to be a match does the predicate then
wend it so that's a pre-processing step
you can think of that as a
pre-processing step sure then when does
the predicate in the join tuples by case
decide that a missing matches with an
actual value I think that's entirely up
to the predicate no no I I agree I agree
but that's that's the choice so that you
think number one that you're doing is
you're you're puffing this out to be
rectangular
okay
and you have some way of doing that okay
that's thing number one I think I
understand that and the predicate can
decide whether it will allow missings in
its comparison or not right whether it
will make whether it will say if it's
three compared to missing it can either
say that always matches or it doesn't
always match make sense yeah okay so
there's this planning function now
interestingly you're right that this is
more like some kind of Association pad
well actually meant someday some
different padding I made analogy with
what was what left and right are doing
it's not the same padding as what you're
now discussing okay but I think this is
a meaningful function because this is
like you know pad left or something
which by the way has that name but if I
say pad left a B C like this I'll get
that yes so basically you're saying that
you can give a second argument the list
of keys and pad any association with the
missing values for those keys if they
are if they're missing that's right but
so now that's the first operation now
the second thing you're saying is
something different I think so this is
saying go ahead what was the second
thing is saying so this yes so set the
second thing is that after you've went
through the entire process of
application the public predicate you can
see you can split all A's into the two
sets they said that survived the
predicate and the set that didn't know
but but the predicate thing was the set
where for some choice of B and C the a
made it into a final result yeah it's
enough that it made it at least for one
choice too because that's the weird
thing that's the weird part of this well
that is there it's a little weird yes
yeah if it would but if you think of in
terms of sets rather than individual
things then divide the a sub I and two
ones that made it
in some way into the final result versus
ones that did not
so
okay I think this we have to look at
this another time but we need more time
on the specific thing yeah that's true
I'm going to send this to Sushma I guess
and you need to reschedule something
this is going to take a solid hour to do
this I think we have made considerable
progress and I think that we will
eventually get something which is really
quite easy to understand and easy to
explain and doesn't look you know this
function has the feature that you might
say why enough do we want this um okay
all right well thanks everybody onward
thanks